Andrea West, Actor: And what about Jenny,
the cheerleader?
Can you just forget about her?
Bedjou Jean, Actor: Oh, Jenny?
Well you know Jenny’s special even if I
never see her again, she’s still special.
Brian Cutler of Brian Cutler On Camera Actors
Studio [Burbank, CA]: Let’s do Andrea and
Bedjou!
What did Yoda say?
There’s no try, there is do and not do and
anybody that doesn’t cold read aloud 30
minutes every day gets doo-doo.
Bedjou: That’s how I read novels because
I can never read anything.
Brian: Right.
Bedjou: I started reading 1984, it’s actually
really good.
I’m cold reading that now.
Brian: George Orwell
Bedjou: Like why haven’t I read that before?
It’s a great book, it’s really good.
Brian: Remember guys, Readers aren’t leaders
but leaders are readers – Harry Truman.
You want to be a leader in any field, you’ve
got to be a reader.
Bedjou: I mean it’s so good that the 30
minutes of…my bell rings and I’m like
really what?
Brian: Good, you time your reading, that’s
good.
How are we in the booth?
Jill Morehouse, Actor/Teacher at Brian Cutler
On Camera Actors Studio: Good start.
Bedjou: Oh, I start, yeah ofcourse.
Jill: We’re rolling, we have speed.
Bedjou: You know what I admire most about
you?
Andrea: I don’t know?
Is it my brilliant mind or my gorgeous insatiable
body the way you're so goddamn cheerful the
way you did the cartwheels today fantastic
nothing to it see the air was champagne and
it made me drunk it's not that easy Chrissy
people are different you're just so open to
people everyone I'm not that way i've got
walls built around me why why not just trade
them down
well I mean it's not that easy like a lot
of [__] up things happened to me when
I was a kid a lot of [__] up things happen
to a lot of people when they were kids maybe
so but i've learned to tune things out not
let people too close I mean work is great
I'm work I'm great at work but people hurt
you and what you don't feel can't hurt you
okay see that's what's wrong philly it's not
feeling what hurts you you've got to learn
to open up you've got to learn to love people
you've got to love stupid people bad ladies
whiners dirty old man and I know how it may
sound but they're people you know they're
live it's and it that's the greatest thing
in the universe it's so beautiful and sacred
and it's free it's all around us just dig
it wallow in it wow you're so damn great Chrissy
okay see I don't understand you I really don't
I don't understand this thing with you and
your grandfather well why can't you just forget
the old fart already it's like a family curse
or something jeez it's hard to explain my
grandfather my grandfather is Texas I mean
he thinks he could buy anything he wants he
tried to buy me once and what he can't buy
he wants to destroy does that make sense to
you not really he destroyed my father no wait
he crippled him you shouldn't ignore wade
you either love him or hate him and what about
Jenny cheerleader why can't you just forget
about her oh Jenny well jenny's special even
even if I never saw her again she'd still
be special oh my god look she dumped all over
you okay just quit moaning about her
I'm sorry Chrissy you're wonderful
come on today maybe some good healthy love
we'll bring it back to your memories so oh
wow very cut there we go lovely good for you
you're you're you know your your english do
you do you realize how much better your english
is now than it was six months ago yeah man
there's just a huge difference and just by
doing it cold drinking a lot every day you
do have the exercise that I gave everybody
right you're doing that you have a lovely
gal from Brazil Portuguese who's working on
that exercise with me and doing a fabulous
job and vasily of course has worked on it
for months since he's been here and it just
shows so you're working real hard at it good
for you that's a lovely work lovely work bed
you okay it's a lot of crap I was like that
there's no cussing in this why did I say that
well I don't care because I haven't said the
f word tonight you thought you'd fill in for
me
yeah we have an f quarter tonight so we're
we're meeting it blank you be quiet you don't
have words for you although you did see it
one night which was quite a wonderful it warmed
the cuckles of my heart he's a big boy he's
in middle school yeah he's heard that word
before yes dad stop talking like that around
the kids
okay good all right let's do it again no I
like what you did just change it up just give
me a different read you know okay
I just go no no you'll get your words from
the booth
all right you start veggie
we are rolling take your own action
you know what I admire the most about you
my brilliant minds or my gorgeous insatiable
body the way you're so goddamn cheerful all
the time the way you did those cartwheels
earlier on fantastic nothing to it you know
the year was champagne it made me drunk it's
not that easy people are different you're
so open to people to everyone I'm not that
way i've got walls around me why though why
not just tear them down it's not that easy
a lot of crap happened to me when I was a
kid a lot of crap happened to everyone when
they were a maybe so but i've learned to tune
things out not to let anybody too close and
work is great I mean I'm great at work but
people hurt you you can't be hurt by things
you don't feel that's wrong Philip that's
not how it works you you've got to open up
you've got to learn how to love people you've
you've got to love all those rhinos and stupid
people and bad ladies and dirty old man because
they're people in their life and that's the
greatest thing in the universe it's beautiful
and it's sacred and it's free it's all around
us digging it wallow in it wow you're so damn
great Chrissy
I don't understand I really don't this thing
with you and your grandfather why can't you
just forget the old fart already it's like
a family curse or something I can't explain
my grandfather my grandfather is Texas I mean
he thinks he could buy anything he wants he
tried to buy me once and what he doesn't buy
he wants to destroy does that make sense to
you I don't think so he destroyed my dad no
wait crippled him but you can't ignore wade
you either love him or hate and what about
Jenny cheerleader can you just forget about
her oh Jenny well you know jenny's special
even if I never see her again she's still
special oh look she dumped all over you just
quit moaning about her you need to understand
that there was a point in my life when my
mother and Jenny were the only people I cared
about okay to hell Jenny what about me oh
I'm sorry Chrissy you're wonderful
Come to bed.
Maybe some good healthy love will help you
bringing you back to your senses.
and cut there we go nice you just shut the
hell out of Philip
I was ready to run upstairs but
good that's good good good good good lovely
good work okay Kenny and Max.